[Inaudible].
Crusades where let me tell you about buzz.
Why let's just call it what it is. Like I said,
Christians versus Muslims is the greatest oldest sports rivalry in history.
And this was the championship.
It was a nine game series and the Muslims won eight to one eight to one. But,
but, but I think when you cross over and get the other side,
I think that the Christians are gonna be you're welcome.
That's the victors you think?
So I think that Muslims have an unfair advantage because Allah is the only true
God that's like having tequila. Well, the reason why I, I mean the,
the thing is with, even on I'm a celibate kid in Muslim heaven,
you can just bang out virgins.
That's what I'm going to Muslim heaven and Christian heaven.
I don't know if you, I wasn't going to the gay part. I heaven.
I'm not going to bang anybody. Yeah.
I think ultimately the Christians went up game one. Yeah. So the first crusade,
there was nine different crusades. Yeah. And the first seven were really like,
kind of relevant to last three. They didn't even make it.
They just got killed along the way. One of them, one crusade.
I forgot what it was. What's on that one,
but that one of them was just Christian.
The Christians went out to crusade and then just started to shading against each
other. I mean,
it's just turned into a civil war crusade before the Christians went out and
crusaded to the middle East and started,
they never had seen any other people that didn't look like them. They just,
they were living in France and Germany and England and not leaving their little
islands or their little huts. So they looked barbaric.
Like they truly looked barbaric with the middle East, what everybody was clean.
They had soaps, they took baths. They ate the right foods. They had science.
So really the crusades are really a bit,
it was kind of the first kind of movement ever where Europe got like
woke Europe. Wasn't woke at all before they met the Muslims. Yeah.
Well, no,
they were and they were with Rome and then they dip down when religion dipped
up. We've talked about that a lot. Yeah. And the Arab world is flourishing.
They also had conquered all the way up to Spain a little bit. Yup.
So they ran sprain. Yeah.
They got up in there and they got up there and they're like, who is this?
Who is his crusades? Yeah. And Europe got split.
Europe was split because of this gives them a 10 54.
Holy Roman empire was split into the East and West.
And also the CA the Christian Church split between the Catholic and
the Eastern Russian and Greek Orthodox what it ended up becoming.
So as Eastern Orthodox and the Catholic split was so, so Europe was sick,
stupid. There were stupid. And everybody in the crusades,
what it was all about was Jerusalem who was sent on another app who,
who Jerusalem was basically like, it was kind of like New York city now. I mean,
what's the most important city in the world, New York city. Right.
So Jerusalem was a very important city to these groups right now.
It was important to the Jewish.
It was important to the mozzies and is important to the Chrissy's because no
matter what, if you believe or not, the kid, Jesus was the star of the kid.
Jesus sold tickets. That kid Jesus sold tickets.
[Inaudible].